Since the dawn of time, humans have harnessed the power of cryptography.
And as a designer, I've always been fascinated by this idea that,...
...through symbols and pictograms and ciphers,...
...you can communicate messages that are only understood by only an elite few,...
..by those who discover the key.
That was our starting point with the Wraith Kryptos Collection.
Could we design a Rolls-Royce that contains a series of secrets within it...
...all hidden behind a unique Rolls-Royce code?
The more we looked into it, the more we realized how powerful it can be...
...when ciphers are hidden in plain sight.
Concealed within Wraith Kryptos...
...is a sequence of encrypted challenges.
To the uninitiated, these ciphers appear on the surface of these...
...to be an alluring design, purely for aesthetics,...
...devoid of any discernible pattern,...
...random even.
But for those who look closer, those very few who will find the key,..
...who can connect the dots,...
...they will embark on a journey of discovery through the vehicle...
...that has an enlightening conclusion.
It is a game with many layers and if you know, you know...
...but for the rest of us, Wraith Kryptos' true power and purpose...
...exist only in the shadows.